ん
amg
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
s 絵馬がカイラスれたのみ約あきこです
30年ほど本を書いたり絵を書いたりする
仕事を続けています
突然ですがこのボール
何色に見えますか
白ですね
みなさんから見たらこのボールは白色なん
です
でも私から見ると
黒色に見えます
このボールを事実
リアルのボールと名付けることにし
ましょう
事実は一つなのに立ち位置によって黒にも
白にも変わりうるという話をお伝えする
ためにここにやってきました
例えば雨
雨の日俺運動会当日の子供達がいると思え
ば雨の日を喜ぶ農家の人がいるように
雨という現象一つをとっても立ち位置に
よって見え方が違います
黒でも白でもないボールを
黒田白だと決め付けることは
思い込みトラップです
私はこれまで人生の中で3度の大きな
思い込むトラップに陥りました
1度目は25歳私はを緩慢か可でした
仕事で東京にいた私は長男妊娠後夫の仕事
の都合で
をクリックへ引っ越しました
今から
初めての出版を控えて東京で一旗あげよう
かという頃
夢半ばで
子育てのために北陸へ移り住んだ私は
い器具に
家族
転勤族
三重苦でままストレスに陥り
10円ハゲができてしまったのです
話す人といえば指廃絶のおじさんか
クリーニング屋のおばさん
誰も知り合いのいない
駅の中で
ポツンと昼間は赤ちゃんと二人っきり
もちろん
赤ちゃんの可愛いのですが
雪に閉ざされて
1人の時はあれもこれもできたのに
もう何もできない
子供がいるから何もできない思い込み
トラップに陥ってしまったのです
雪が解けて少し心が解放されると私は子供
を連れて子ども図書館へ通い始めました
そこで仲良くなった館長さんに
あれもできないこれもできない
とぼやいていましたら
館長さんはいいました
やっている人は行っているよ
ジレンマに陥っている時
人は周囲が全く見えなくなりますが
手を差し伸べてくれる人
ピントくれる素が必ず現れます
私はその人のこと
背中押しの天使と呼んでいます
やってる人をやっている
館長さんの一言でハッと気づきました
できない私ではなく
やっていない私を自覚し
受け止めたのです
先輩ママたちも
できない理由を探さず
制約がある中でもできること
やっていったんだと思います
私は急に焦り始めました
ゆうちょんで愚痴ってる場合じゃないなぁ
と
タイミングよくオーストラリアにいた妹が
行為をかけてくれました
子供と一緒に来てみたらあっ
点と点がつながり始めました
やってる人やっている私がやりたかった
こと
旅好きだった私は世界一周
夢見ていたんでした
子供がいるからできないと思い込んでいた
けれど
やってみなくちゃわからない
泥沼の中から
一歩でも踏み出そうともがいていたんだと
思います
私は着々と準備を進めて
パパ抜き子連れ旅
2歳の息子と2ヶ月オーストラリアと
トーナーじゃあの食べに行きました
母子
ベビーカーを押してのバックパッカーです
お金は抜け出しの貯金から
夫は子供に世界を見せてきてくれと応援し
てくれました
いざ旅に出てみると
子供がいるからできないと思い込んでいた
度は子供がいる方がはるかに楽しかったの
です
ゲストハウスで母子でいると世界中の
ファミリーが
寄ってきてくれました
鳥た人は違う
旅の楽しみ方があるのだとわかりました
あれもできないこれもできないと思ってい
たのは私の頭の中だけ
黒だと思っていた某るー
一歩踏み出てちょっと覗いてみたら白色が
見えた a
あれ半分白色ちゃん
気づいたのです
を子供がいるからできないが
子供がいるからこそできるに変わった瞬間
でした
気づけば
思い込みトラップからも抜け出ている自分
がいました
トラップから抜け出すと
子どもといる日々の小さな小さな幸せを心
から楽しめるようになりました
2度目のトラップは40歳
私は
オカンと私大生になりました
40歳で神戸大学理学部生物学科に編入学
したのです
なぜ理学部に入ったかというと
物書きの仕事で若い頃に患っていた腰痛
それをきっかけにヨガを始めていたんです
が
東洋医学としてのヨガを学んでいたんです
ね
でその頃
統合医療が叫ばれ始めました
もう一方の西洋医学生命科学を
アカデミックに学びたいそして伝えたいと
受験したのです
なにを隠そう
す式を見るとこじんま疹が出るぐらいに
数式アレルギーの私
数式が全部暗号のように見えました
理系コンプレックス思い込みトラップです
学生たちとを除いた本格的な理系の授業や
講義は
前代未聞の
ちんぷんかんぷん
すべてが暗号のように思えました
そう大ピンチです
モル計算や化学式は
新潟だけど
できないことはできる人に頼めばいいの
です
私は開き直って受け止めました
それからは二十歳の学生にランチおごり
作戦でピンチを乗り切りました
そもそも私を悩ます瓜形ってなんなん
でしょうか
教授は言いました
理系の分野は数学ができるできないじゃ
なく
結果を分析する公設力が大切なんだよと
そうか文系だから理系はできないと
思い込んでいたけれど
考え抜く力なら
理系も文系もないのかもしれないなぁと
気づきました
ここでも背中押しの天使が舞い降りたと
いうわけです
私がのぞいた生命科学の世界は本当に神秘
と不思議と感動に満ち溢れていました
細胞の中はどうなってるの
がん細胞ってどうやっていけるんだろう
遺伝のしくみってどうなってるんだろう
基礎化学糊学の分野は私たちの生活の根幹
を支えていると気づきました
その中でも菌やウイルスの理生物ドン世界
は私の学生たちがあくびをしているその
世界すべてが私にはとても新鮮でした
例えばおにぎりって家庭によって味が違う
って知っていますか
母の味って言うんですけれども
常在菌によって味が変わるのです
そういう話や私が毎日毎日悩んでいた
旦那の加齢臭が
おねがーるという菌が原因だったことを
またそれは木や銅のイオンの聞くという
こと
他にも
腸内細菌が
心に左右しているということ
などなど生活に
生きる知恵の宝庫だったのです
理系の部位だと思い込んでいた分野を
文系の主婦の私がのぞいたら
学問として面白がる視点が違うことに
気づきました
こうして微生物学の分野を
振っ系の女で切り取った実用書が生まれた
のです
専門的な話は専門家に任せていればいいの
です
コンプレックスも
逆手に取れば武器になります
私はこうして理系コンプレックスからも
抜け出しました
3度目のトラップは50歳私はオカン社長
になりました
法人化とともにコロナに翻弄されたのには
参りましたが
個人で進むには限界があって
チームとして拡大するためです
数式アレルギーなんですから
軽軟體全くわかりません
現在系なんてできない思い込みトラップに
絶賛ハマり中です
でも出来ないからこそ
学びたいと思います
先輩の経営者は言いました
商売は人に感動を与えること
数字を追うのは苦手だけれど
感動を与えることならできるかもしれない
そう思うと思い込みトラップから抜け出せ
そうな気がします
そして
もしかするとこの会場にいる誰かが次の私
の
背中押しの転身になるかもしれません
ところで思い込みトラップを抜け出す方法
って一体なんだったんでしょうか
もう一度この白黒リアルボールの登場です
白 pro
できるできない
eval 位
三極の思い込みトラップから抜け出す方法
は
白だ黒だと決めつけずに
ちょっとだけ立ち位置を変えることです
目の前にある現実を
ありのまま
ただ淡々と受け止めます
事実を事実として受け止めます
そうすると
次第に白黒のニュートラルの立ち位置が
築けると思います
受け止めることができたら
背中押しの店主の声も聞こえてくるかも
しれません
ぎゃっ館的な二点も生まれるはずです
そうすると他に各一方
一歩だけ
踏み出してください
そうすると立ち位置が変わってきます
立ち位置が変わると見える景色が違ってき
ます
誰しも
落ち込んでしまったり立ち止まったりする
ことがあると思うんです
でもその時は
どうぞこのボールを思い出してください
そして
ちょっとだけ
立ち位置を変えてみてください
このボールが何色なのか
決めるのは私たち次第なのです
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]